es ist februar es geht wieder richtig
los im garten und schaut mal wie viele
zusammentun ich mir hier gepackt habe
denn ich werde euch in diesem video
zeigen welche gemäße wir jetzt schon
anbauen vorziehen draußen auszählen raus
pflanzen können und da fangen wir mal an
mit der anzucht im haus oder starten wir
mit den brokkoli den könnt ihr jetzt im
haus vorziehen ich hatte jetzt die sorte
linda gewählt dass man sich deswegen
weil das eine sehr schnell wachsende
frühe sorte ist und andere sorten eignen
sich dann besser um sie später im jahr
aus zu sehen und dann könnt ihr auch
mangold vorziehen normalerweise bei euch
ganz gerne die sorte rainbow an das ist
eigentlich so ein sorten mixed wo ganz
viele unterschiedliche bunte mangold
pflanzen mit dabei sind so dass man dann
rote und gelbe und pinkel und weise hat
dann machen wir weiter mit einem etwas
exotischeren gemüse bzw eigentlich es
ist ein kraut es ist der schnitt
knoblauch das ist so ähnlich wie im
schnittlauch so dass er mehr nach
knoblauch schmeckt und winterhart ist
das heißt man kann in diesen ganzen
winter über auch beehren ein ganz tolles
wintergemüse und da sehe ich jetzt auch
pro auszahlung 45 samen in ein schälchen
und dann kann man die später auch ins
freiland pflanzen ist eine super sache
also probiert das auf jeden fall mal aus
wenn ihr noch nicht mit knoblauch
angebaut habt kann wird zu den salaten
so früh im jahr sehe ich ganz gerne die
sorte bacchus und ihr wahrscheinlich
wenn ihr meinen kanal kennt ich habe
auch mein altes samentütchen von dieser
sorte gefunden schaut mal ich hab das
ursprünglich von sativa gekauft ich weiß
nicht ob es das da jetzt noch gibt wenn
ihr irgendwie an sabathil saatgut kommt
dann schlag zu weil das ist eine ganz
tolle frost hatte sorte aber ich sehe
jetzt auch ein salat aus und noch ein
paar andere kopfsalat sollten die dann
einfach im frühbeet kasten oder ins
gewächshaus wandern aber wenn du jetzt
salat fürs freiland vollziehen möchtest
dann ist es schon besser ein bisschen
frost härtere sorgen
und süßkartoffeln kannst du jetzt auch
vorziehen das wollte ich eigentlich im
januar video schon zeigen und hab da
vergessen dafür schneidest du eine
süßkartoffel knuddeln ungefähr kartoffel
große stücke die hier habe ich jetzt
gestern schon angeschnitten so dass die
schnittstellen gut abtrocknen konnten
denn packst du die in einen topf mit
erde vergräbt sie so dass man noch ein
bisschen was von der knolle sehen kann
und lässt sie gut angefeuchtet bei
ungefähr 20 grad zimmertemperatur stehen
so dass die triebe austreiben und so
kannst du deine eigenen süßkartoffeln
aus knollen ziehen
du kannst auch im herbst stecklinge von
deinen alten süßkartoffel pflanzen leben
die ins wasser packen und dann in töpfe
pflanzen und im haus überwintern dann
geht das ganze noch ein bisschen flotter
aber wenn du keine süßkartoffeln hat es
letztes jahr oder das nicht gemacht hast
dann kannst du dir so aus knollen neue
pflanzen ziehen weiß cool geht jetzt
auch schon so früh im jahr sehe ich am
liebsten erst mal schnell wachsende
sorten aus die dann auch schnell früh im
jahr im sommer gleich einen guten ertrag
abwerfen und für die herbst ernte war
ich dann ein bisschen später im jahr
langsam wachsende hre lager so hatten an
die sich auch gut für die sauerkraut
herstellung eignen eine seite die ihr
euch da sehr empfehlen kann ist nagels
frühe weist die hat uns noch nie
enttäuscht und die wirft ganz früh im
jahr schon die ersten weißen köpfe ab
das eine super sache und dann kommen wir
zu einer sache die vielleicht ein
bisschen umstritten ist und zwar sehe
ich ende februar also jetzt nicht anfang
februar oder ende januar wenn dieses
video erscheint sondern erst ende
februar die ersten tomaten aus für das
gewächshaus man sagt ja oft wartet die
tomaten er noch bis mitte märz weil wenn
man die zu früh vor zieht dann wird das
nichts da müssen die zu lange im haus
ausharren bis sie dann nach draußen
gepflanzt werden können das stimmt auch
allerdings pflanze ich unsere tomaten
gerne schon im april ins gewächshaus und
damit die dann auch fertig sind wissen
die eben auch früher im jahr vorgezogen
werden wenn jetzt aber nur freiland
tomatenanbau dann wartet auf jeden fall
noch bis mitte märz bevor ihr die ersten
sorten in die erde gibt und wenn ihr
euch fragt welche sorten ich euch da
empfehlen würde da habe ich schon mein
ganzes eigenes video drüber gemacht dass
linke ich euch gerne unten in
video beschreibung schaut euch das auf
jeden fall mal an übrigens ist seit
vorgestern meinem gemüsegarten staaten
videokurs wieder in die neue runde
gegangen das heißt jeweils fast ein jahr
ausverkauft und jetzt nehmen wir wieder
neue teilnehmer auf und ich bin total
aufgeregt neue leute durch die
gartensaison zu begleiten und freue mich
unglaublich wenn ein paar von euch damit
dabei sind das ist eine ganz tolle sache
also wenn du lust hast dein garten
dieses jahr auf ein neues level zu heben
und zu lernen wie du ihn wirklich
ertragreich pflegeleicht und wunderschön
gestaltet so dass du deinen garten zu
deinem absoluten traumgarten machst dann
freue ich mich wenn du mit dabei biss
der link ist unten in der video
beschreibung und in den nächsten tagen
gibt es auch einen saftigen rabatt zum
kurs start in die neue gartensaison
eigentlich ist es gar nicht so als ob
der winter das der schlimmste jahreszeit
so als gärtner wäre weil man da finde
ich noch ganz schön viel eines super
viel gemüse aus dem garten ernten kann
aber ich finde die zeit zwischen mai bis
anfang juni wo man eigentlich nicht viel
aus dem garten ernten kann
viele sagen deswegen finde ich solche
tollen sorten wie wodurch soll es ein
ganz früher blumenkohl super toll weil
man sich da durch diese ernte lücke die
man im späten frühjahr hat wenn die
wintergemüse abgeerntet sind und die
sommergemüse noch nicht reif sind super
gut fühlen kann deswegen ziehe ich den
jetzt vor ich werde ihn dann auch ins
gewächshaus pflanzt und sobald er so
weit ist und dann so pflanzen dass die
tomaten zwischen die blumen kohlköpfe
gepflanzt werden können wenn die dann
raus kommen ins gewächshaus so dass wir
da dann bevor die tomaten den platz
richtig brauchen noch eine frühe jugend
wohl ernte einfahren können aber den
könnt ihr auch jetzt vorziehen um ihnen
zwei land zu pflanzen müssen ganz schön
schnell wachsende sorten
dann kamen wir zu einem tollen sommer
gemüse und zwar der überlegene ist es
jetzt auch zeit aber liegen brauchen ein
bisschen um in der jungpflanzen an sucht
in die pötte zu kommen und deswegen ist
es ganz klug wenn man die jetzt schon im
haus vorzieht so dass sie dann mitte mai
nach draußen gepflanzt werden können
eine tolle freiland sorte für überwiegen
die man auch draußen anbauen kann wer
die sorte blaue königin ansonsten hat
jackie mich extrem angefixt mit der
sorte baden
ich hoffe man spricht hier so aus ich
weiß es leider nicht so genau aber mit
der hat sie super erfahrung gemacht und
von der sie super begeistert und paprika
es jetzt auch zeit da habe ich auch eine
tolle freiland sorte für euch die ich
euch empfehlen kann das ist die sorte
rote augsburger und gewächshaus wächst
bei uns die sorte juli wonder richtig
gut die macht superschöne dickwandige
glockenförmige paprika wie man sie so
aus dem supermarkt kennt also nicht
diese dünnen freiland paprika dazu auch
super lecker sind aber solche kann man
auch zuhause anbauen wenn man
gewächshaus hat und jule wanders ist
eine ganz tolle sorte und da machen wir
weiter mit rotkohl rotkohl kann man
jetzt auch aussehen um ihn dann später
ins freiland zu pflanzen ich baue gerne
die sorte granat an
ich muss aber sagen dass ich finde dass
rotkohl so eines der schwierigsten
gemüse ist die man so anbauen kann also
wenn du gerade erst anfängt mit dem
gärtnern dann würde ich diese
schwierigeren kandidaten erst mal fürs
erste jahr zumindest außen vor lassen
und mit ein paar anfänger freundlicheren
gemüsearten starten wir sehen ist ein
kopfkohl den ich sehr einfach finde
anzubauen also der macht nicht so viele
zecken wie seine verwandten und da
kannst du jetzt auch schon deine ersten
wilsing pflanzen selben so früh im jahr
sehe ich nur sommer wirsing also wir
sind die männer im sommer erntet aber
wir singen ist ja eigentlich ein
klassisches wintergemüse und den hinter
wilsing brauchst du jetzt auf jeden fall
noch nicht vorzuziehen
kann ein kandidat den wir im januar
video auch schon hatten die ziellinie
ich habe mich doch dazu entschieden dass
wir doch dieses jahr trotzdem obwohl wir
noch ganz viele zuließen yahoo hat
kammern haben welche anbauen bei uns
landet dieses jahr eine neue ziel die
sorte im bild die wir noch nie
ausprobiert haben die heißt positano und
die hat mich von sich überzeugt bei sie
sich gut zum trocknen und chilipulver
verarbeitung eignet und die früchte im
haus nach reifen können nützlich gut an
oder
und dann kommt ein tolles blümchen ist
zwar kein gemüse aber ich möchte sie
trotzdem mal hier mit aufnehmen das sind
die paket ist eine ganz tolle
mischkultur pflanze die dafür sorgt dass
dein
hatten schön gesund bleibt wenn du
diesen mischkultur effekt haben willst
dann solltest du darauf achten dass du
gewürzter geht es anbaus also diese hier
die wandert bei uns auf jeden fall jetzt
auch ins beet und die kann man jetzt
wunderbar im haus vorziehen dann ein
gemüse das mir nie gelingt und ich weiß
nicht was ich falsch mache aber ich
schaffe es einfach nicht wenn anzubauen
das ist das einzige gemüse mit dem ich
wirklich probleme habe und die letzten
zwei jahre habe ich deswegen einfach
kein ventil mehr angebaut und den kopf
in den sand gesteckt aber dieses jahr
war ich noch mal sind versuchen eine
sorten empfehlung kann ich euch da jetzt
nicht wirklich geben weil wie gesagt bei
mir wachsen alles schlecht ich habe
jetzt mal die sorte finow ausprobiert
vielleicht habt ihr ja irgendwelche
knollen versorgten sie ihr total gut
findet dann würde ich mich freuen wenn
ihr einen kommentar da last weil ich
will dass es dieses jahr wirklich klappt
weil meine familie liebt mich und es tut
mir total leid dass ich es nicht
hinkriegt ihn selber anzubauen darüber
werden sich meine jungs auf freuen ich
habe nämlich auch petersilie ausgewählt
das ist jetzt auch ein guter zeitpunkt
da habe ich auch mehrere samen in 1 1
doch töpfchen gemacht und so pflanzt
sich sie dann auch gebündelt nach
draußen wenn sie dann so weit sind die
sollte die wir angebaut haben heißt
einfache schnitt 3 ein eher
ungewöhnlicher name aber sie taugt auf
jeden fall und hat sich bei uns gut
bewährt dann habe ich jetzt auch noch
mal zwiebeln gesetzt weil ich fand dass
ich im januar video ein bisschen wenig
zwiebeln ausgewählt habe und da habe ich
zwei neue sorten ausprobiert einmal
globo und tosca die haben mich total an
gemacht in irgendeinem garten katalog
der letzten viertels angekommen ist so
von den erfahrungswerten kann ich euch
eher stuttgarter riesen empfehlen
red baron spricht spricht einen baron
auf englisch aus werden
auf jeden fall ist es eine tolle leute
die rot ist die lassen sich beide auch
total gut lagern und die kann ich euch
sehr empfehlen
und vielleicht kann ich euch nächstes
jahr auch eine von denen empfehlen wenn
die sich gut bewährt haben mal schauen
dann ein gemüse dass wir schon länger
nicht mehr angebaut haben aber ich weiß
nicht ob ihr die youtube kennt nicht so
ganz tolle
videos wo sie ganz viele krasse sache
gemacht und an bord und verarbeitet und
am ende ganz tolles essen auftischt und
die hat letztens tatzeuge erntet und ich
fand ihn zurückschicken in ihrem video
das ich auf jeden fall dieses jahr auch
noch mal welchen anbauen will ist ja
eigentlich eher ein wintergemüse das
heißt eigentlich baut man den er später
im jahr an aber du kannst ihn eben auch
jetzt auswählen und dann eine ganz frühe
ernte im jahr haben ich werde ihn dann
ins gewächshaus oder in den briefkasten
und pflanzen damit es dann auch
hoffentlich schnell klappt und ein ganz
tolles gemüse dass wir dieses jahr nicht
aussehen aber dass ich auf jeden fall
mit aufnehmen möchte ist die artischocke
geschaffen sind ja mehrjährige pflanzen
und tanz haben unsere beiden
artischocken pflanzen bisher sehr gut
über wind hat so dass wir dieses jahr
keine neuen jungen pflanzen brauchen
aber das ist eine ganz tolle sache die
brauchen ist ein bisschen geschützt also
ich hab dir jetzt hier direkt vor dieser
sandsteinmauer gepflanzt hinterm
gewächshaus so das sie dann wirklich gut
geschützt sind und dann habe ich sie vor
dem winter über dem boden abgeschnitten
günstig mit laub gemulcht und hoffe dass
sie so überwintern also bei uns erfahren
eigentlich immer mal wieder ein paar die
schoppen pflanzen aber es kommen
meistens genug durch dass wir trotzdem
noch eine gute ernte haben die tragen ja
meistens erst im zweiten jahr nur wenn
man ganz viel glück hat kriegt man auch
schon im ersten jahr ihren tabletts
gemüse habe ich euch im januar video
auch schon vorgestellt die rote bete die
kann man jetzt auch im haus vorziehen
und das dauert auch nicht mehr lange bis
wir die auch direkt ins freiland wählen
können das mache ich nämlich viel lieber
weil wir essen ziemlich viel rote bete
ich finde das mit der anzucht macht zwar
spaß aber bei diesen gemüsen wie
zwiebeln oder rote beete wo man wirklich
machen braucht wenn man sich selbst
versorgen will
für mich ist ein bisschen mühselig die
alle im haus vorzuziehen und sehe die
lieber direkt ins beet aus aber das
würde ich als im februar
erst nur noch nicht machen aber es gibt
ein paar gemüse die man jetzt auch schon
ins freiland sehen kann und das wäre
einmal wenn das radieschen die werften
ja auch ganz schnell näher
ernte ab also das sind so ziemlich die
am schnellsten wachsenden gemüse
überhaupt wenn ihr noch ein paar mehr
schnell wachsende gemüse sucht die ihr
vielleicht auch mit kindern zusammen an
bauen könnt wo man richtig schnell eine
erste ernte hat dann schaut gerne mal da
oben vorbei oder in der video
beschreibung dafür linke ich euch das
video zu meinen raketen gemüsen die
superschnell geerntet werden kann
und dann sehe ich im februar und märz
auch immer meine kompletten pastinaken
aus also alle patienten die wir dann im
herbst und winter essen wollen da
empfehle ich euch sehr gern die sorte
aroma die ist sehr lecker und auch sehr
ertragreich und dann bauen wir oft auch
noch die sorte halblange weise an
ich finde das immer ganz klug wenn man
unterschiedliche sorten kombiniert ich
mache das auch gerne dass ich die alle
zusammen mische die samen weil
unterschiedliche sorten sind ja
unterschiedlich resistent gegen
unterschiedliche krankheiten und
schädlinge und so wird es einfach mit
deinen garten einfach resilient wenn du
sorten mixe selber mist weil wenn dann
ein schädling kommt und der hat es vor
allem auf die aroma abgesehen aber
zwischendurch immer wieder die halbe
lange weiße steht dann kann er sich eben
nicht so durch fressen oder irgendeine
krankheit kann sich nicht so schnell
verbreiten wie will man nur eine sorte
aussieht also das mache ich ganz gerne
dann passt zur pastinaken auch ganz gut
die karotte karotten kann man je nach
wetter auch schon im februar aussehen
dann aber nur wirklich frühe sorten wenn
du meinen kanal schon länger kennt dann
kennst du bestimmt auch diese sorte ich
erzähle immer mal wieder von ihr die
sorte gonsenheimer treibt eignet sich
dafür richtig gut die serien wir ganz
früh im jahr schon aus und dann müssen
wir sie aber auch wenn sie aufgegangen
ist ein bisschen mit stroh oder schützen
sie mit einem garten fließt damit sie
richtig aufgehen kann
und ein bisschen vor dem brauen
frühlingswetter geschützt ist dann
kannst du jetzt auch erbsen sehen da
starte ich so früh im jahr gerne
zuckererbsen weil die sind ein bisschen
weniger frostempfindlich als die mag
erbsen möglichen normalen gemüse herzen
und da war ich ganz gern die sorte
ambrosia an bis eine super leckere sorte
und ab märz kommen dann auch die marke
bei uns in die erde und die gemüse
erbsen aber die zuckererbsen stecken
forst ein bisschen besser weg deswegen
sind die ersten im jahr und eine sache
kannst du jetzt sogar nach draußen aus
pflanzen das sind die salat glänzen die
du vielleicht im januar vom gezogen hast
wenn du hinter salatsorten vorgezogen
hast wie zb bei kiel oder die winter
marie dann kannst du jetzt auch schon
ins freiland aus pflanzen wenn du dir
gut abgehärtet hast das heißt wenn die
an das draußen leben gewöhnt wurden um
für eine woche lang wo du sie immer mal
wieder nach draußen gestellt hast am
anfang für eine stunde dann führt zwei
stunden dann mal einen ganzen vormittag
erst im schatten dann in die sonne und
so weiter dass sie sich wirklich daran
gewöhnen können wie es ist wenn man in
den wilden draußen garten entlassen wird
dann würde ich dir aber immer noch mit
einem gärtner fliesst abdecken so dass
sie gut vor frost geschützt sind und
andere salat sollten die nicht besonders
winterhart sind kannst du jetzt auch
schon in deinen frühbeet kasten oder in
ein gewächshaus pflanzen zur geschafft
der salat mit gepflanzt denkt immer
daran dass ihr salat ein bisschen höher
pflanzt als er im topf gesessen hat das
ist ganz wichtig damit ihr euch nicht
weg foult spinat kannst du jetzt auch
aussehen vielleicht nicht unbedingt ins
freiland wenn es noch richtig kalt ist
wenn ich bei dir gerade noch schneit
dann sowieso die finger davon lassen
dann noch ein bisschen gedulden das ist
ein bisschen wärmer ist aber wenn es bei
dir schon einigermaßen warm ist wie
jetzt hier bei uns wir haben jetzt so
fünf grad manchmal auch sieben grad
tagsüber und nachts keinen frost dann
kann man auf jeden fall auch schon
spinat ins freiland allen dingen auch
immer noch mit einem gärtner fliesst vor
den rauen temperaturen aber das klappt
dann sehr gut und dann hat man auch also
spinat ist auch so ein gemüse was man
dann schon sehr schnell bald ernten kann
und was diese lücke gemeingefährlich gut
schließen kann ich ganz gern die sorte
winter ließen
oder wer die heißt die auch manchmal das
ist eine sehr frostharte sorte und
sobald es dann wärmer wird braucht man
eine chance festere sorte das heißt dass
die nicht so schnell in die blüte geht
weil gerade ist eigentlich bei vielen
wintergemüse so dass sie sehr schnell
blühen wenn es dann wenn die tage länger
werden und es wärmer wird und das heißt
schießen also man nennt das in der
gerhard noch sprache schießen da muss
man dann ein bisschen variieren auch
beim salat baue ich im sommer eine
andere sorte an als im winter bei den
mühren auch und das ist ganz klug wenn
man da ein bisschen variiert aber ich
weiß dass es gerade auch super schwer es
saatgut zu bekommen wenn ihr
irgendwelche tipps habt wo man noch
saatgut bestellen kann in bioqualität
viele shops liefern ja im moment gar
nicht mehr oder machen nur für ein paar
stunden am tag den shop auf und ich weiß
dass viele von euch da gerade große
probleme mit haben schreibt gerne mal
unten in die kommentare wenn ihr einen
job gefunden habt wo man im moment noch
gut saatgut bekommt weil ich glaube da
sind ganz viele leute dankbar für wenn
du deinen anbau plan noch nicht erstellt
hast dann schaue gerne da trieben vorbei
da zeige ich dir wie das geht es ist gar
nicht so kompliziert wie man sich das
immer vorstellt und ansonsten sehen wir
uns nächsten samstag wieder für ein
neues video macht es gut hieß